welcome back to the real rejects i'm
greg alba and i'm greg alba i'm john
yeah you're john we're gonna watch today
from new rock stars
the mandalorian luke skywalker sighting
i'm ron burgundy
grogoo seeing sewn stone scene
okay we get yeah you guys get where i'm
going out with this let's see if their
theory holds true as the episodes unfold
like
i was excited to check out some eric
voss
speaking at a whiplash pace
welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
boss and the mandalorian season 2
just reached out in its biggest way yet
to the star wars universe network of
jedi a link that maybe may have been
made with luke skywalker since the
mandalorian is set five years ago so
after returning to the jedi we
know luke is alive somewhere in the
galaxy and thanks to ahsoka tano's
guidance to track down other jedi
via the taithon singing stone that
leaves very few
other jedi grog who could have connected
with it yes presumably ezra bridger is
out there
from jedi fallen order that would be the
best
guy but i'm gonna explain based on what
we know about luke's history during this
period
and subtle clues in the recent
mandalorian episode why
a cameo by mark hamill luke skywalker
might be
the most likely scenario that i will
never have to own up as a mistake let's
remind ourselves where luke
is at this period the mandalorian is set
in nine aby
about five years after the battle of
endor four years after the empire's
seemingly final route in the battle of
jakku
the new republic has established a new
government on chandrila and in this
period various x-wing pilots now patrol
the galaxy trying to establish new
republic footing in the outer rim worlds
they are worried about a growing threat
there though
in the battle of jakku luke skywalker
was training his sister leia as a jedi
we saw this in a flashback from the rise
of skywalker but then
in 5 aby leia gave birth to her son ben
solo and her priorities shifted oh so
kylo's already born
of the mandalorian luke is not yet in
his exile a notch too he's right
again no new jedi temple is being built
it's still too early for that his
training of ben solo would not begin
until then who is 10
and 15 abyss six years from now and then
six years or so after that luke would
fail to find hexagon with lando we saw
that in the rise of skywalker 2 and then
in 28 aby is when luke fights with ben
solo and loses ben to the first order
and then luke goes into exile on osh 2.
but back in 9 aby
we know that luke at this point is on a
vast search for knowledge about the
history of the jedi in the sith he teams
up with lor san tekka max feinstein al's
character from the force awakens
santeka helps luke damn i gotta read
these comics
luke's journey takes them to catalinta
as well as the sit-home world of the
show's recordings
once you tackle one media go to the
match
luke during a search period also finds
the personal archives of jedi temple
librarian jocasta new
and learns about jedi masters like mace
windu and qui-gon jinn
as well as dark side warriors like dark
bane darth maul darth tyranus and
inquisitors who hunted the jedi during
the galactic civil war we also know from
yeah
that luke had previously found a compass
in the emperor's observatory on
paleo which is what helped him find his
way to ash to begin with the most
important detail when it comes to luke's
link with mandalorian is
luke's whole search for the first jedi
temple he was pretty obsessed with it so
during this period
he has learned about the lothal jedi
temple and he obviously knows about
notch too
so presumably he would also know about
this ancient temple on taithon first the
moonstone that grogo uses has either
already been visited by luke skywalker
or will soon be discovered by him or was
just discovered by luke
this episode we might have seen it
happen here okay there's a very good
that would be cool folks noticed earlier
in this episode that mando's dashboard
display on approach lists orbish text
which translates to
region core and we've learned from that
protocol droid teacher star map back in
chapter 12 that the core worlds
are the location of the new republic
center of government so titan isn't one
of those
remote hard to find worlds like gosh two
is tython probably would have been one
of the first stops on luke's search
and then upon this stonehenge on clip
top are some visual
clues the butterflies these might be
linked to a dark vader comic in which
vader visualizes himself in his mind's
eye
a violent gnarly form except these blue
glowing butterflies flapping about those
represented the light side of the force
still
in him the redemption
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you not believe this become that
fear girl
the beam blasts up from this ring of
runes around the stone
these ruins are written in the old
tongue the sith language but a language
also used by ancient jedi
they were on a sith dagger in the rise
of skywalker rebels animators put them
on the temple of lothal
and the ruins of malachor but at the
time those runes didn't translate really
to anything they're just kind of like
nonsense randomly put in there and many
of the symbols were backwards they were
put in inconsistently this was
before the production designers of the
mandalorian have been really good at
making sure all the visual text
translates into something which you'll
watch my recent breakdown in chapter 14.
i translated pretty much all in
unfortunately those production designers
and editors were also
really good at making sure these runes
are too faded two weathered down
trust me i spent hours trying to do this
there is not a single character that
matches to the
alphabet that's so clever
they've been watching
i love how they couldn't figure it out
it's so funny could translate to the old
jedi code there's no emotion there is
peace there's no ignorance there's
knowledge
there's no passion there's serenity
there is no chaos there's harmony there
is no death there is the force just
because
those words were so important to the
other ancient jedi temple we know of the
tree on ash too which could be heard as
whispers
blurring in rey in the last jedi
now there was that kind of creepy detail
with the scene stone when mandel leaves
to go down to confront boba fett at the
base of the hill behind him
up in the hilltop two figures are
visible in the ring of the stones
assuming one is grogu who is the other
is it the tip of one of those other
stones i was about to say
the best suspect is luke skywalker and
even if that's not the shadow of luke
skywalker there grog who talked to
someone and i assume that person is luke
skywalker
just because of the remaining jedi alive
in the galaxy the only one
known to be exploring i'm going to get
so hung up on that little detail
yeah where would that extra rock be
physically standing on that
[Music]
oh
this is so good
he could have still been there just on
an earlier visit scouting it out that
remote projection is how i suspect we
would see
luke skywalker this season of the
mandalorian if that does indeed happen i
don't think we're gonna see a dh
mark hamill crystal clear resolution but
kind of
creepy in that uncanny valley kind of
like joining all these characters
in the same exact space by the way i
also don't think we're gonna see those
fan pushes of sebastian stan to play a
younger luke
that looks good i was like wait a minute
cannibalizing attention on other actors
of a younger luke that's flickering in
and out of resolution so we don't really
focus on all the little bfx details this
could be something that he accomplishes
before he perfected his force projection
resolution
in the last jedi
or even more simply folks the voice of
mark hamill could echo
us soon
either way i have a feeling this season
the mandalorian is going to reveal to us
luke skywalker's exploration of the
history of the jedi by taking us
someplace we have yet to go
inside the mind of the child oh hey by
the way if you are interested in getting
any of our great mandalorian merch
options ah [ __ ] i gotta get that
today i would recommend purchasing it
why you want it to be delivered by
christmas just because right now as far
as i know new
shipping company can really guarantee
christmas delivery so if you want one of
these things as a christmas gift for a
loved one which i think they make
love what means absolutely
dude dude that got me pumped very
compelling
that got me pumped that was yeah that
was so
well put that i already believe it to be
true
that's how good i thought this one was
there's just too many connecting dots
with new rock stars you know like i you
always got they're theories right
there's usually theories and sometimes
they're
really right and sometimes they're not
that's the thing with theory channels i
usually freak out
once i'm like oh my god i think they've
proved it
yeah when it's really that compelling
and you can see all the time
you can see every thread on the board
coming to one little center point
yeah and really around the blue
butterfly part was when i was like
if that is not a visual indicator i
don't know
what it is yeah yeah that alone when the
blue butterfly showed up
my mindset thought i i've seen them in
clone wars before
and i i think they are i didn't know
about the comics obviously
and so to have it be the whole thing
with darth vader how it represents the
light side in him it just makes sense
when you think about
how interwoven this episode is where
in the last one you had ahsoka tano who
was
darth vader's or anakin skywalker's
apprentice and then you go into this one
and then if you're alluding to luke
skywalker in a sense
with the butterflies i think that's
really cool but then also tying it into
the last jedi with the meditation on the
rock being something that seems very
similar
and the whole thing with the force
projection too that luke did in last
jedi i just it's just
all too it's all there i mean i i
honestly think eric vos did it i
wouldn't want any other answer at this
point
this is the way this is the way exactly
because i mean partially too it's like
if this is such a rare
and an incredible creature anyway to be
sitting on the stone to be generating
this huge reaction
channeling out to any other jedi in the
universe it seems like it would make the
most sense and it would be
the most important to luke who had such
a relationship with
yoda just to even meet another one of
his kin through that link and yeah it
would make a lot of sense that he might
not be there at that exact moment maybe
he had to
project there right where they were
alone or something like that to
you know commune or whatever kind of
similar to the mental communication or
whatever from the previous episode but
one thing this got me thinking of was
as the mandalorian expands you're
thinking okay well what's the bigger
end game of the show and then i started
to think if this is what they're going
to do i mean they've already brought in
they've already shown that they're good
at bringing in
both new things from the extended canon
that we haven't seen in the live action
but also honoring things from the
classic films and whatnot
and it almost seems like the mandalorian
as a character would make a lot of sense
to
interact with or run into tangentially
like maybe that's gonna be the ultimate
point of this character is to have him
bump into various characters that we
know and love
on his journey with the child that is
kind of the new part of this
you know what i'm saying no yeah yeah no
yeah you're taught you're you use it as
a way to kind of
wrap up or link it in canonically to
other characters like how they've done
with boba fett right now like how
they've done with the socatano yeah i
get what you're getting at
to me it just makes the most sense to
have it be luke skywalker i don't really
know the timeline stuff
as as well like if i think about it hard
enough i could probably like i could
link it in with the movies
and what i've seen from the show at this
point in in the galaxy
there's not many jedi left it's like you
got ahsoka who's not oh some people go
back and forth like she really a jedi
you know she's not technically a jedi i
think in
the grand scheme of things i would just
call her jedi why not
even though she did leave the jedi order
i understand but then you got cal
out there but in terms of like the story
of the mandalorian
we already got ahsoka it would just make
more sense
the one who was closest to anakin
skywalker perhaps
might find some type of forced
connection or something like that with
luke skywalker
in some variation i'm sure she's maybe
heard stories of him right so then to
have it be luke skywalker to be the one
to show up he hasn't started training
ben solo yet he is on the mission
everything they're talking about
from last jedi and the missions that
luke skywalker was doing from like
training leia
to going through hexagonal unless you
like introduce a new jedi or that mace
windu theory comes true
right now when you're thinking about the
movies and how much it's tying in
luke skywalker does make the most sense
this feels the most spiritually sound
yeah
yeah and i don't know how they pull it
off uh that's that is a big question i i
don't think mark hamill wants to return
and i it would be weird to see this
de-aging on him
i think we'd just be way too aware that
like yeah it's definitely
filoni needs to fix everything one by
one
but that's actually part of my
skepticism going forward because
when you look at how clone wars made the
prequels
better a big part of that was the fact
that george lucas still was involved
with clone wars
here with the disney sequels that's what
they are they're the disney sequels
and they didn't even run with george
lucas's ideas and now these guys
favro and filoni who are very much about
honoring
the lucas world not the disney sequel
world they're now tying it into the
disney sequel world i'm really wondering
was this part of the whole vision with
the mandalorian to begin with was this
part of their discussions like how how
can we
mesh this show into the disney sequels
to make the disney sequels feel more
like canonically star wars important to
relevance because i always get a little
tense when they come to the sequel
footage here
yeah it's like like this isn't this
feels like this doesn't shouldn't matter
as much
well and that's the public opinion very
much so and the mandalorian was
developed at a time where they were just
still
dropping the last sequel and now it's
got to occupy a weird space where those
do
still exist and at least for the moment
haven't been
retconned out of continuity it's another
one of those things where i just i hope
the point of the show isn't to prop up
those
sequel stories but i can definitely see
how justin
doing this thing and and i don't know
like you said it makes spiritual
sense that it would be luke and in that
way if they do happen to include him it
would probably at least
lend some extra flesh lend some credence
to the journey of where he goes later if
they do decide not to again
wipe the sequels from existence i just
don't want it to be that they were
forced into having to talk exactly yeah
i don't want this to be like we need to
fix these
and we're going to use your show to do
it right now the way it's going is
pretty neat and cool
and it's working for me and i know
there's more
than the disney sequels to tie it into
as they were like going through the
comics and all this stuff the books the
games even like
going through all those that i'm not as
familiar with i mean we'll see
so far i'm enjoying it i love the idea
of luke skywalker showing up and i have
faith
like some the utmost faith in what
filoni and favreau can do storytelling
wise
to make this all feel like it's just a
smooth journey even if it does help
complement the disney sequels better
to make it more than just calling it the
disney sequels you know
one that's what i hope that eventually
the star wars universe becomes is just
one
big universe for all the movies and
everybody is just there
blemishes and better points yeah yeah i
mean we're there we're
almost there give it ten more years yeah
give it another film franchise to to
overshadow the sequels and make them
look better and then we'll be good all
right guys amanda lauren keep a lookout
for
season two episode seven reaction coming
this weekend subscribing to new
rockstars if you haven't done so already
click the notification bell for us as
well subscribe hit that like button if
you enjoyed our vid last but not least
jn valente i just want to say to jn
valente
merry christmas to you buddy i really
appreciate the amount of support you've
shown us these last couple years
you've never left our side sometimes you
might ghost us on some messages and then
come back later
to provide us with a lot of messages
regardless you've always stuck by our
side
you've been a constant christmas gift to
us for years
you make christmas all year round you
wacky son of a [ __ ]
and i love that about you that's right
getting a message from you is like a
blizzard a
flurry of wonderful words ideas visions
of the world
yeah try replying to it once in a while
you'll have a great time
from the one or two half replied to it
is always a dream
i go i'll tell you jan you're a sweet
son of a bee
and i'll always love you man i wish like
one day to meet you
and see it was like we were like in
person yeah i want to
see what you're liking messages i can
only imagine what you're like in person
we should get a drink sometime in chat
like a character out of an hp lovecraft
novel just
drunk and gone mad and it's just
rambling and equally yeah
like what is this
but then you know we'll walk away from
that story with some kind of real lesson
that'll haunt us for the rest of our
lives
thank you jan for being you